now you use the GoPro you said for a few
the shot yeah I used to go pros yeah at
the time it was the hero to the three
wasn't out yet but it was phenomenal a
little camera and it held up on you know
the big screen when I put it on those
shots for the big screen
I used the 1080p setting and I use it as
a security cameras in the house and I
would just move it from place to place I
also use it as there's a this it's
called an eyeball it's like an Israeli
military camera that has 360-degree view
and I used it for the view of that as
well I put a little green filter over
top of it but when Gary holds up that
and it's the POV of that ball I used
that and then there's also a shot where
a guy gets decapitated and I used it at
his his POV as his head rolled pretty
well I had to design a special rig for
that GoPro where I bought a hamster ball
actually bought a few of them because in
case I destroyed one of them I bought a
hamster ball and I waited it and I
forget what I used it but I had just
like duct tape and toothpicks and pieces
of like nuts and bolts that were using
it I was using as weights cuz I don't
have anything like this is it you know a
couple days before we had to shoot it so
I had to work quickly and make it do
what I wanted to do but it was I had to
be able to drop it and let it roll a few
feet but land exactly where I needed
land without somebody touching it so I
figured it out somehow
late at night one night and I just made
this rig and it was it would probably
work like three or four times where it
broke but it worked - the first time I
used it I used it I just had it sitting
there and I dropped it and I let it roll
and it just got the perfect shot and we
used it in the film it was pretty cool
after sending some pictures of that one
it was not pretty to look at but it
definitely worked and we tested it a few
times I have some footage of it us
testing it and we're like
that works it's awesome
you